this is 38 year old Simon lingard after
he left his home in the UK for the front
line in Ukraine he spent months fighting
Russia's Invasion but on Sunday he
promised his son he'd be home within
weeks he was killed the next day a shot
just thought it was indestructible
with hero to everyone he just stood up
for what he believed in thought to hear
that he weren't here anymore it was just
a really big block at a memorial in his
hometown in Lancashire Simon's family
and friends grieved the loss of a man
who was determined to help others
everyone tried to stop Simon it was his
old man nothing was stopping him if he
wanted to do something
he stood up for what he believed in he
thought it was wrong and he went to help
them
I'm extremely proud of Simon so his
children fly I Soldier Gonna Miss You
Grimmer those who knew Simon Often by
his nickname Grimmy say he had a heart
of gold under a tough shell he struggled
after the end of his career as a
paratrooper in the British army watching
news coverage of the war in Ukraine he
and a friend made up their minds to go
over there we were just like nearly
crying looking at each other and
thinking I've got to do something and he
said I've got to do something Simon
became extremely close to the men he was
fighting alongside he could have left
but he just didn't want to leave him
because they were like Brothers now but
they were like 20 or 30 in them and they
were doing missions and they were
sending them out all over to the front
line and you know the man he's done some
amazing things he's saved many many
lives over there for what he's done the
Ukrainian military are arranging for
Simon's body to be brought back to the
UK his family have already crowdfunded
thousands of pounds to help with funeral
costs to give their hero the send off he
deserves Becky Cottrell Sky News